good day everybody and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr david van essen the alumni
endowed professor of neuroscience at washington
university in st louis dr van essen completed his
bachelor's degree in chemistry in 1967
from the california institute of technology
and in 1971 he completed his phd in neurobiology
from harvard medical school his professional
experience includes post-doctoral fellowships at
harvard medical school of the university of oslo
and university college of london in england since
1992 he's been based at washington university
in st louis where he has cultivated an impressive
and successful career in human and non-human
brain anatomy his model of the huma the primate
visual system is now enshrined in the historical
canon of neuroscience and he has made immense
contributions to the field of neural informatics
the sharing of primary data and the processing of
neuroimaging data in particular the computational
modeling and detailed mapping of the brain's
cortical surface importantly in partnership with
dr camille ugerbill of the university of minnesota
dr van essen leads the nih-funded human connectome
project a massive scale effort to map the extent
and the structural and functional connectivity
of the brain using neuroimaging methods as
a consequence of all his important work to
understand the brain and the role of computational
approaches in so doing dr van essen has received
numerous awards acknowledgments and recognition
from leading scientific organizations in the us as
well as internationally he's also held many major
leadership positions helping to direct research
policy and practice for the brain its informatics
and computation his lecture today is entitled
mapping structure function and connectivity in
humans and non-human primate cerebral cortex
as always we are streaming
this lecture live for recording
via youtube if you're watching via youtube we
welcome you and thank you for joining us also
us for our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants you are
encouraged to submit any questions for dr vanessa
via the chat feature in your zoom sessions i will
synthesize these questions and i will ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of
dr vanessa's lecture and with that welcome david
we are very much looking forward to your lecture
thank you jack for that generous
introduction for the chance to talk to you
about the cerebral cortex and structure
function and connectivity issues that i've been
engaged in for many years now i'd like to start
with some big questions about how does the brain
work to make us unique as a species unique as
individuals gifted with amazingly diverse talents
unfortunately afflicted by devastating brain
disorders at all ages and stages of the lifespan
i think we can all agree that deciphering
the brain in health and disease
is truly a grand challenge for this
century if not the millennium beyond
i also want to emphasize in this talk how there's
increasing dependence on data science to move the
needle forward and chop these challenging issues
so i'm going to focus on healthy brains and the
cerebral cortex and the neuroinformatics
aspects of how we tackle these issues
i'd like to start with some basic numbers i
love anatomy and numbers about the brain we
all have about three pounds of squishy tissue
inside our skull and the brain contains uh
almost 100 billion neurons the dominant structure
whether you look at it from the lateral aspect
or the slice through from a coronal plane or
a medial aspect of one hemisphere the dominant
structure is the cerebral cortex which contains
about 80 percent of brain mass if you count the
gray matter and white matter together and it is
of course responsible for an enormous diversity of
functions cognitive sensory perceptual motor
and so on uh it does its job using only about
20 of the brain's total number of neurons
and that's because it's a chock-a-block full
of 10 000 or so synapses per neuron
and 150 trillion or so grand total
the white matter cabling uh linking one gray
matter region to another contains on the order
of 160 000 kilometers worth of myelinated axons
the pint-sized cerebellum on the lower left is
only about 10 of the brain's mass yet it contains
an amazing 80 percent of the neuronal total
and it works in coordination with cerebral cortex
and other circuits to coordinate our movements
and also our thoughts the rest of the brain is
less than 10 of brain mass contains fewer than
one percent of all the neuronal accounts uh and it
contains literally hundreds of subcortical nuclei
and subnuclei that are collectively responsible
for quite a wide variety of critically important
housekeeping functions to handle our thirst
and hunger and many other drives and behaviors
so for this talk we're going to start with
some basics about cortical cartography
how we make maps past and present how we look at
cortical connectivity in animal models the second
big chunk will be on the human connecting
project that jack has already introduced
and then i'll talk about data sharing and
neuroinformatics aspects before we wrap it up and
have time for questions so our brains are about
three times larger than that of our closest living
relative the chimpanzee we're 15 times larger
than the intensively studied macaque monkey
that you'll hear more about 200 times larger than
the marmoset of increasingly popular experimental
preparation for primate studies and 2 000
times larger than the intensively studied
mouse brain you can also see at a glance that
the cortical convolutions vary enormously in
the degree of folding and the pattern of folding
and it's those folds that made me a cortical
cartographer when i started working almost 50
years ago on the macaque monkey cereal cortex
and i took a cue from cartographers of the
earth's surface where we take a a corrugated
spherical surface of the earth and flatten it
out and display on maps of the earth flat maps
many different types of geographic political and
cultural and economic varieties of information
for the cerebral cortex when i started the
computers weren't up to the job and so i literally
had to invent a method using pencil and tracing
paper to make the early vintage flat maps of
here the mount the monkey cerebral cortex where
we showed the geography by representing and
grade the regions that are buried in seoul side
but we could take these maps and represent uh
information about the functional organization
of the cerebral cortex by identifying various
cortical areas based on information about function
architecture connectivity and or topography
and there were a few areas like primary visual
cortex v1 and little red area mt in the middle
that were poster children because they could
be identified by any or all of these different
approaches and they gave pretty much the same
answer but most of the other areas on this
this map although the borders were drawn
sharply on on the representation uh the data
behind them was fuzzy and there was a lot
of debate about what was one area or another
we'll come back to that because it's critically
important to have maps as accurate as possible
we also dan fellman and i looked in the early
days at the connectivity inferred from studies
reported in the literature and we identified at
that time hundreds of pathways just among the
several dozen visual areas known at the
time and we posited this hypothesis that
the connectivity supported uh the idea
of a distributed hierarchy in which
various visual areas are early middle or late
stages of information processing and we generated
a binary connectivity matrix showing the
presence or absence of pathways known at the time
we knew that connections varied in strength but
didn't have any hard data on that so we had to
put that on hold but you will come back to that
because it's very important but to make progress
in the field it was really important to get
better methods of map making and when structural
mri imaging came on the scene in the 1990s various
labs ours included started making cortical surface
models using computational methods and the leading
methods nowadays is without question the free
surfer method uh pioneered by bruce fishel and
colleagues and uh that method with high quality h
human connection project hcp data lets us
capture the outside and inner surfaces of the
of the cortical sheet the cortical ribbon and
then to take the middle of that surface and make a
geometric model that we can spin around
and also inflate so to as we smooth it
out the regions that are darker on the smooth
surface were deeper in the original uh 3d brain
if we do this for many different individuals and
take a look at the these issues of individual
variability from one person to the next of healthy
young adults we see that they aren't all the same
they're like different fingerprint patterns and
we can see those similarities and differences
more easily by looking at the inflated maps on the
right where again the darker it is the deeper it
was in the 3d uh original configuration so in some
regions like the red arrow pointing to the central
sulcus everyone has the same sulcus in about the
same region but actually in most regions there
is remarkable variability in the folding pattern
from one person to the next and amazingly that's
true even in identical twins so lo and behold
there's two pairs of twins here uh it's very hard
to tell until i give you the cheat sheet answer
and and you can be informed that the left and
right pairs here are from two twin pairs uh and
there is actually some heritability when you look
very carefully but what once is struck by is the
the striking degree of differences even amongst
identical twins working with the same genetic
instruction kit another critically important issue
is that cortical areas vary in size so in this
lower right panel the red outlines the primary
visual cortex and the left and right hemispheres
from three different individuals and you can see
these these differences in size and also the
differences in relation to nearby folds uh that
springs to mind a question of what
is it that makes the cortex fold
and i have a story that i'm going to encapsulate
down to a simple nutshell summary i hypothesized
some years ago and i'm currently revisiting this
the idea that mechanical tension along the axons
that connect one region to another across long
distances if those axons are under mechanical
tension they may be the physical force that
drives the folding uh in a systematic way but
i'm going to skip over further discussion of that
and move ourselves on to the question of cortical
connectivity returning to what i'd schematized
a little while back when we looked at original
brain maps in order to look at the connectivity
systematically we need better more accurate maps
of the underlying cortical organization so
i mentioned that the map on the upper left
was an initial approximation there are more
recent models including a 91 area parcellation
shown in the upper right based on cortical
architecture another one that contains 164
areas by a different investigator paxinos
some years ago we synthesized a hybrid across
several different data sets and and generated
what we call a composite map but the reality
is uh for the macaque monkey we still don't
have an accurate map of all the cortical areas
and we'll see in contrast there's been more
progress on in other species the mouse and human
to be specific but using the parcellations at
hand we can look more closely at these issues of
cortical connectivity by taking a tracer injection
uh shown here for an example area if we inject a
retrograde tracer into cortical area 7a and then
slice up the brain postmortem the red dots and the
next panel here show the location of retrograde
labeled cells at various distances across each
slice and when we stack those together and
assign the total number of area of labeled cells
for each cortical area we get on the lower left
a quantitative map colorized to show the density
of inputs from different cortical areas to the
injected area 7a this is actually a logarithmic
plot and on the lower right you see that there's
an amazingly systematic log normal distribution
such that the strongest connections on the upper
left are literally five orders of magnitude
more dense than neuronal inputs than the weakest
connections coming from the lower right so this
is a basic principle that holds for all cortical
areas that have been examined we can also take
data that's currently available from 29 injected
areas out of this 91 area parcellation and see now
a quantitative connectivity matrix it gives us a
a much more accurate assessment of the the wiring
uh that underlies uh cortical circuits and
brain function um there's still need to
assess this using even more accurate methods
that are what we call parcelation free and
getting those more accurate connectivity maps
is something our lab is currently doing in
collaboration with henry kennedy and france
if we take the same issue and apply it for the
mouse brain that i alluded to a few moments ago
in the upper panel there you see a top-down
view of both hemispheres of the smooth brain
glycine cephalic mouse cortex much smaller much
smoother and andreas burkhalter has pioneered the
process of taking that smooth brain and literally
physically flattening it not computationally but
squishing it between glass slides and then
cutting the brain the smoothed out cortex
tangentially and using anatomical
methods he's been able to identify
41 distinct cortical areas and we think this is
actually pretty close to a ground truth estimate
of the parcelation in to many distinct
areas but not nearly as many as in primates
uh and working also with henry kennedy andreas
and burkholder and colleagues have identified uh
even richer denser connectivity within the
cortical network in the mouth so nearly all areas
are connected with all other areas the only ones
that have no connections are the the scattered
ones shown in black there so the cortex is in
this sense a densely connected distributed network
also amazingly it's now possible to reconstruct
using different anatomical techniques
the full complexity of individual neurons so
in in the red arrow that's pointing to a single
labeled neuron in motor cortex of the mouse
and uh right next to the arrow you can see that
the distribution of the dendritic arbors in the
immediate vicinity but then branching out uh is
a single axon that branches profusely and makes a
huge number of connections on both the ipsilateral
and contralateral side so this gives you a sense
of what individual neurons are doing and now think
of billions of them finding their pathways and
setting up shop and communicating with one another
it gives you an idea of the staggering complexity
that we have to grapple with in trying to
understand how any brain works and that brings
me into an exciting modern world of connectomics
the principle of systematically looking uh at
connectivity as comprehensively as possible
but we have to put that comprehensive in quotes
because uh uh the challenges of working with uh
the scales from microscopic to macroscopic
uh pose uh uh exciting uh daunting but also
challenges that can be tackled so there's an
exciting world of the so-called micro connectome
that strives to use electron microscopy and other
ultra high resolution methods to identify every
single synapse axon dendrite glial cell cell body
the whole kit and caboodle and reconstruct that
as extensively and accurately as possible and
there has been uh exciting progress and success in
reconstructing the microconnectum uh for up to
a cubic millimeter uh already and in the offing
in the decade or so to come is the prospect
of reconstructing the entire mouse brain at
the micro connecting level so that will be uh very
exciting and and something to from a data science
perspective uh to salivate about the
ways to explore that using sophisticated
uh tools there is in parallel this uh second world
of what i like to call the mesoconnectum using
the kinds of pathway tracers that i've already
illustrated looking at local and long distance
connectivity across the whole brain at a light
microscopic resolution to identify connectivity
in experimental animals the mouse and marmoset
and macaque monkey included i currently live
most of my research time in the macro connecting
world of human neuroimaging where we use mri based
methods for the most part uh to infer what we
can about structure function and connectivity
in living human brains with the resolution element
the voxels we work with uh generally being on the
order a millimeter or two on the side and bear
in mind uh that each cubic millimeter contains
literally hundreds of thousands of neurons and
millions and millions of uh synapses so our
resolution has to cope with with those anatomical
realities so but that's the realm of the human
connectome project to which will now turn our
connection but i want to say a little bit more uh
well actually we're going to jump right
to the human connection project now so
a decade ago the nih funded two human connect
home projects uh jack was involved with one
ucla then usc working with mass general hospital
i was involved with the washington university
minnesota and oxford consortium where we
aspired to get data on brain structure function
and connectivity in 1200 healthy adult twins
and their siblings using state-of-the-art scanners
improved pull sequences to get higher quality data
and getting an unprecedented four hours worth
of multimodal imaging data from each subject
we ended up successfully getting data on 1100
subjects scanned with the three tesla scanner
at washu 200 of those subjects also flew up to
minnesota and were scanned at higher resolution
with the seven tesla scanner uh a hundred of the
participants went over to saint louis university
and got magnetoencephalography scanning which is
exciting because it gives much higher resolution
in time but at the price of a coarser resolution
in space but it is another complementary modality
in addition we got extensive behavioral
demographic and genotyping data
to buttress the imaging data that i'll be
mainly focused on when we analyze the data we
developed and consolidated a set of pre-processing
pipelines that are absolutely critical for
taking full advantage of the high quality
imaging data that we were able to acquire
and i'll illustrate how we were able to achieve
improved alignment across subjects a map to more
accurate atlases and bring powerful visualization
tools including the connect and workbench platform
that my lab has spearheaded and we developed
advanced analysis methods for looking at
relationships between connectivity and
behavior and looking at more accurate
cortical parcelations that i'll illustrate
in a short while another key issue is our
enthusiasm about sharing the data as well as the
methods and tools i'll illustrate the connectum db
database for sharing the primary
and minimally preprocessed data
as well as the balsa database that facilitates
sharing of highly analyzed data and almost 20
000 investigators have signed on to using the
the data and more than a thousand publications
uh uh emerged today using this the data sets
the the neural imaging paradigm that
we introduced as we developed these
these methods and analysis strategies uh
are summarized with seven core tenants that
are published in uh nature neuroscience
paper that i encourage people to look at
the first of them is uh i've touched on
before it's really important to get as much
neuroimaging data as one can in any given study
subject to practical constraints of costs and and
subject tolerance but it needs not only a lot
of data but multiple modalities so that they
can complement one another and for each modality
it's really important to get the highest facial
resolution possible given again scanner and other
practical limits and to pay attention to other
aspects of data quality we found that the
multiband uh mri for functional and diffusion
imaging uh is extremely important and essentially
providing more bang for the buck getting more data
per per second yields excellent benefits once
the data is acquired it's really important to
minimize the distortions which lurk in most
modalities of the data and also be attentive to
not blurring the data so as not to waste a high
quality resolution that one uh acquired another
important principle is to respect the geometry
of brain structures and by that i mean for the
cerebral cortex you've already seen visually the
benefits of using surface models and that's all
well and good but for the subcortical structures
which lurk inside the cortical core it's really
important to use uh volume elements uh voxels and
we developed a hybrid representation that we call
the safety format uh that combines the benefits
of growth approaches and an efficient strategy
once one has data as analyzed as carefully
as possible across individuals it's really
important to align the data precisely across
individuals and across studies and and that's
not has not been uh traditionally done with
conventional volume based imaging but i'll
illustrate the benefits of doing it carefully
and uh when the data have been analyzed
it's really important to use accurate brain
particulations to the degree that's feasible
for any given species and lastly but certainly not
leastly the principle of freely sharing the data
from the raw to minimally pre-processed to
publication related is critically important
and is now much more feasible than it was
a few years ago so let me illustrate uh
by a few examples of why it's so important and
valuable to get high quality data and process
it carefully so when matt glasser came to my lab
more than a decade ago he had actually noticed
anecdotally that in a conventional t1 weighted
image such as this horizontal slice through the
top of a brain that in the cortical gray matter
ribbon some regions are a little bit darker than
average other regions are a little bit brighter
than average and very importantly if you take a
t2 weighted image that looks like this next slice
here it has essentially the opposite contrast the
csf is bright the gray matter is gray and white
matter is dark but in that gray matter ribbon
the region that had been darker in a t1 weighted
is now brighter in the t2 and vice versa for the
the other example region so by taking the ratio
of that uh and colorizing it it canceled out some
inconvenient biases and allowed for more
accurate mapping of uh the t1 to t2 ratio
onto the cortical ribbon which revealed
the pattern that was strikingly similar to
myelin maps that have been evident from classical
brain studies so the sensory motor strip
auditory cortex and visual area mt are all
known to be heavily myelinated and they show
up with with a high t1 the t2 ratio so it's
not a perfect quantitative marker but it's
a qualitatively extremely useful especially
if one aligns accurately across many subjects
one gets these kind of beautiful myelin maps
that you see on the left panels here and
in the same subjects one can also get a
different anatomical marker of cortical thickness
as shown in the the middle panel uh the right
panel shows the range of thickness from over about
a two-fold range from less than two to up to four
millimeters and so each of these patterns gives us
strong indications of regional differences and
by taking the spatial gradient and computing
that and analyzing it carefully one can identify
aerial features and prospective aerial boundaries
that run along what we call gradient ridges and
one can use that to identify just with these
two anatomical methods some cortical areas
but in the bluish and indigo regions uh the
fluctuations in myelin and thickness are
are more gradual and less revealing about
functional organization so that's comes back
to this point why do we need many modalities
it's informative in many ways and including for
the issue of cortical parcelation that we'll come
back to in a short while but let's take a look
at these other modalities starting with diffusion
imaging and then um after touching on that briefly
looking at a second modality of functional mri
so with diffusion imaging the action is mainly in
the white matter and as you may know the diffusion
and coding ingredients are structured in such a
way they probe the the for the orientation or axis
on which water diffuses most freely most rapidly
and that correlates with the orientation of
axons fiber bundles in the white matter so
for each little voxel of one and a quarter
millimeters we were able to get for the hdp one
can estimate the dominant orientation but also
a probe for evidence of whether there are crossing
fiber bundles uh which is hugely important because
there are indeed many fiber bundles crisscrossing
throughout the white matter organization
and then one can use probabilistic tractography
methods to infer trajectories of fiber bundles
including those that are crossing through any
given voxel so one can carry out this tractography
approach to estimate long distance connections
from one seed region in the blue dot shown in the
example to other regions and one can infer gray
matter to gray matter connectivity as shown in
by the reddish regions in the lower right panel
here so it's exciting that one can get information
indicative of trajectories within the white matter
and gray matter degree matter of connectivity
but lurking under these pretty pictures are some
uh hard-nosed realities which in a nutshell are
that there are many false positives and
false negatives and systematic biases
even in the best tractography data to date and
so one has to be extremely careful uh to not
over interpret uh the data that comes from this
and it's a really complex issue if you have more
questions i'd be happy to touch on them further
in the discussion period but in the interest of
time let's move on to a functional mri which
comes in two flavors the first of them is the
the conventional task evoke functional
fmri to use a structured task to modulate
oxygen consumption and the so-called
bold blood oxygen level dependent signal
that fmri yields and deanna barch pioneered
spearheaded how we approach this with the
hcp project in the hours worth of time allocated
to task fmri we carried out seven different tasks
i'm going to very quickly illustrate three
of them language tasks listening to stories
in the scanner versus doing arithmetic mentally a
social cognition task looking at moving triangles
and saying are they moving randomly or are they
hugging and kissing and dancing in a way that
one infers social interactions amongst these icons
lastly a working memory task is the image you see
right now the same or different from what you
saw two images two back ago we're going to
fly through this looking at maps of functional
mri task evoked signals on maps of the
cortical surface that have been smoothed out on
the left brain slices and mapped to a cerebellar
flat map on the right panels so here's what
happens listening to stories versus a baseline
you see the reddish and yellow regions of high
activation in temporal and frontal cortex uh
evident in a symmetric pattern in both hemispheres
though stronger on the left uh hot spots indicated
by the arrows also in the cerebellum is uh
language related uh regions as well if you
take the next task in line the social versus
random that i mentioned you see there's partial
overlap some of the regions are strongly activated
by both tasks but many other regions are activated
in the the social versus random that are not
seen in the in the tap in the language activation
and the third quick example is the working memory
tasks that's more complementary but still a bit
of overlap basically the long and short of it
that we have time to touch on here is that for
any given task that you're doing in the scanner or
in your daily activities it invokes a complex set
of partially overlapping and dynamic networks not
just one hotspot when you're thinking about what's
two plus two and another hot spot four seven
minus four and so on it's a very divergent uh uh
complex network uh in some ways uh akin
to the complexity of network of anatomic
connectivity i've illustrated in the first part
of the talk switching over to our next major and
last major modality resting state fmri if one lies
in the scanner and thinks about who won the game
how was the debate what for dinner what are we
going to do tomorrow the brain is very active and
that's those fluctuations that occur
can be probed in a systematic way
by taking any pair of gray matter regions gray
ordinance as we call them looking at the time
signature the fluctuations and asking for each
pair of all possible pairs are they correlated
anti-correlated or where in between and that
can be converted into a functional connectivity
matrix as we call it also a dense
functional connectome by another lingo
that we can see as a this matrix or we can probe
it interrogated one row or column at a time and
say for seed region one uh who is it correlated
with and it turns out there's a systematic pattern
consistent in broad strokes with the anatomical
patterns we've seen in the in the monkey regions
that are close to the seed region tend to
be more likely to be correlated but some
long distance regions are highly correlated as
well on the same as well as opposite hemispheres
and for another seed region you see a different
pattern and one can milk that for many good
purposes uh even recognizing that this functional
connectivity measure is really highly indirect and
assuredly is by not the same uh in a quantitative
sense as a tracer-based anatomical connectivity
something we're very interested in but i don't
have time to talk about it but you can ask me
later if you're interested so how can we use these
multiple types of information for interesting
analyses i don't have time only to talk about one
that's my favorite which is the issue of cortical
parcelation that you've heard about already in
other species if we come to this for the human
brain were bequeathed with a century-old classic
map based on just the cellular architecture or
cyto architecture that the great german anatomist
brodemon painted onto a surface model or a
surface drawing also a century ago working
in parallel a cecil and auto boat identified
almost 200 areas using myelin saying versus
brodemont's map of 50 areas and for a century
uh the debate followed as to which one was more
likely to be accurate in recent decades mri has
chimed in with indications of functional
connectivity maps giving evidence for
network organization of an intermediate kind
of pattern randy buckner's lab has provided one
parcelation shown in the lower left panel steve
peterson's lab has produced an even finer grain
model but that's incomplete and also not as
symmetric across hemispheres as one might expect
but these uh fmri based essentially unimodal
parcellations represent a major forward progress
but don't provide us consensus within
themselves and when matt glasser and i uh
focused more intensely on the hcp data
we found that it was possible to get more
accurate partialization by taking advantage of the
multiple modal types of data you've already seen
looking for information about architecture as
well as topography and connectivity and function
in combination and to let regions be defined
uh when there's consistency of radiant ridges
that agree across modalities uh then we were
more confident that we were on the right track
and as you'll see briefly that proved
to be successful not only for getting
a group average of parcelation but
for individual subjects as well
so to cut to the chase after an intense and
very focused analysis matt was able to identify
180 cortical areas in the left hemisphere a
matching set in 180 areas in the right hemisphere
functionally organized by broad color schemes
to show regions related to vision sensory motor
auditory or more cognitive regions as colorized on
the map we gave each of these areas labels 83 of
them agreed with classical names in the literature
so we just was kept with the same name 97 of them
uh were fine or grand or entirely new and
so that summed up the total as you see on
the map there matt was able to apply an aerial
classifier algorithm to identify these areas in
in all individuals and show that they
vary in size shape and precise location
so just give you a quick flavor of that here's
a group average parcelation late overlaid on
a group average myelin map here's one individual
subject's parcelation overlaid on its own subject
and mile and partici here's one particular
area here in another individual you can
see the same area but it doesn't
have the precisely same location
another group allen and tijevitz and
michael cole were able to take the
acp data and identify uh functional resting
state networks of the type that the buckner
and peterson labs had previously uh pioneered but
now uh using uh matt's parsolation to identify
12 distinct resting state networks in the
human brain as assessed by this approach
so um in the last few minutes let me move on to
these exciting and really important issues of
uh neuromatics aspects of uh that were coming from
here and i want to start with one that builds off
the cortical parcellation that i just saw you
because i just showed you a lot of people have
been interested in and not just seeing the pretty
pictures in a nature paper but actually working
with these uh data sets the partial basin itself
and the and the functional uh and other modalities
of maps and we made it really easy for people to
do that if you uh literally look at the online
journal and look at the figure legend there's a
little url sitting there and if you click on that
you jump immediately over to our balsa database
which gives you a preview of that same figure
and basically lets you tap into this by logging on
to balsa which is easy and just saying i'd like to
after i've agreed to the day to use terms i'd
like to download that data set and lo and behold
you can download uh the data and launch connect
on workbench and replicate that very same figure
uh and work with the data and the subsets that you
want for your your own analyses and you can take
other uh as we call them scene files that
characterize uh each of these uh figures
and you can get a scene file with
all the labels painted on the surface
for aid and identify identifying one area
versus another so the balsa database is now
encouraging investigators for all neuroimaging
studies to work with the connecting workbench
scene file platform upload your data uh and
share it with the work with the community
and and over 2200 users have tapped into the
dozens of studies that are in the database so
far but we'd like to build that up um more
aggressively in the in the years to come
and uh i emphasize that these scene files are
useful not only for data sharing but for just
in-house working with complex data sets and making
uh sophisticated accurate figure preparation
jumping over to the earlier stages
of processing dan marcus at washu
spearheaded the establishment of a robust
connectomdb database that is how we shared the
particularly the minimally pre-processed
hcp data and the connect on pb provides for
rapid easy access uh to various combinations
of data prepackaged data sets or drilling down
and searching for individual subjects or groups
of subjects meeting a particular behavioral or
imaging quality or other aspects of the acp
metadata that we provide to work with these data
sets and literally uh 14 petabytes of data have
been downlighted downloaded by almost 20 000 users
uh to work with the hcp data and generate the the
thousand-plus publications i already alluded to
so moving forward from the original young
adult acp which wrapped up in 2016 there
are many other projects that are acquiring and
sharing hcp style data that i've touched upon the
lifespan projects in aging and development
are going to be wrapping up next spring
to provide and share data
from more than a thousand
older adults for the aging projects and young
children 5 to 21 for the development project
a major release coming in a month or so and then
one final one at the end of the project there are
also 14 what we call disease connect home projects
that are also in late stages of acquiring and
analyzing and sharing data altogether 4 000
subjects will be in this collection of uh
projects uh uh each project dealing with
a particular disorder depression psychosis
and so on and dan marcus and i have
spearheaded the connectome coordination
facility to handle the informatics or these
for processing them systematically with
hcp style pipelines and providing the data making
it ready for data sharing i'll come back to the
data sharing aspects in a moment but i just want
to touch upon a couple of others the abcd project
is even more ambitious it's a 10-year project
to follow 12 000 kids from nine years through
the teenage decade there's a baby connectome
project that's got exciting data on very young
ages a british prenatal and neonatal project the
uk bio bank project again pushing another envelope
a hundred thousand subjects uh albeit with
only 30 minutes of scan per subject so there's
staggering amounts of neuroimaging data being
acquired shared and analyzed and one of the key
events recently was an nih decision that data
sharing for these projects rather than being
localized in institution-based repositories
are in general going to be coming into a a
cloud-based nimh data archive uh and uh
an aspiration uh that nimh is pushing on
uh is that even for smaller projects but
projects of any side with imaging genomic
uh and other modalities of data uh should be
uh planning to get their data into this uh nda
archive there's some important issues to be worked
out for the community to shift over to the this
nda cloud-based domain the data access isn't as
straightforward as we were had been able to make
it for the young adult hcp but it is manageable
and nih is encouraging investigators to get
accustomed to working on the cloud for data
analysis that's going to be developing rapidly
in the years to come and i think the data
science community that you guys represent
can really play an invaluable service to
the community in helping uh establish and
that infrastructure and make it robust for a
wide variety of analysis strategies on the cloud
as well as what one can do by downloading the
data and bring it into the laboratory and val
environment so to wrap it up uh in brief
summary we've seen evidence of the importance of
looking at cortical particulation great progress
in many species particularly humans and mice
i've given you strong indications of how
extraordinarily complex cortical connectivity
is but it's an organized set of networks
in a distributed hierarchical configuration
uh neuroinformatics which jack and i have been
engaged in for uh literally decades has gone from
uh a an outlier out in the boondocks uh domain
of science to a front burner exciting field
of research that again you guys are helping to
spearhead uh and uh there's a tremendous amount
to be done uh using the new tools applied to these
very rich data sets particularly the hcp style
that i've emphasized gives a lot of value added
for studying development aging brain disorders and
will give us progress in the future so one quick
analogy just to drive some of these points home
we have classical maps of the earth
and the brain book atlases and
the brain and earth satellite imagery was
revolutionary mri is revolutionary for brain
imaging google earth as you know has been utterly
transformative uh that and other technologies for
navigating at an immense range of range of scales
seamlessly and literally at your fingertips
we look forward to continued exciting project
progress and in the field of connectomics to
let us navigate the brain at the immense range
of spatial scales that are needed to decipher
its organization and function so what
i've been able to tell you about is
due to tremendous efforts by people in my lab
our collaborators henry and takuya a fantastic
team of individuals for the young adult hcp
and the successor lifespan projects and the
generous support of funding agencies so i'd be
happy to discuss any questions that you may have
david thank you so much for sharing with us
this really it's a tour de force amount of
work to map the brain and its form and function
both from some of your early work that which you
you summarize but also this just impressive
amount of science that has been born out of the
human connectome project and all of its derivative
projects it's just so exciting as a source for
data and an opportunity for computational
types to dive into that data to model it to
be able to synthesize it and turn it into
new knowledge and i want to encourage our
innovation lab participants to send in any
chats that you have for dr van essen via the
zoom chat feature um while we're waiting
for some of those to pile up david i want to
ask you that kind of as you noted i think it
was kind of a general thread throughout your
talk was that the brain possesses multiple scales
of measurement and multiple scales of resolution
from cells to systems from synapses to cortical
shapes from you know time as well as spatial
aspects and while many researchers tend to stick
within their particular space show temporal slice
of area of research what are you envisioning or
can you tell from the human connectome project
what we need to do to actually transcend some of
these scales of measurement and what sort of data
science might be needed in order to do that my
short answer is i think it's a great opportunity
and my instincts are that we need
literally a new approach a new brand of
computational strategies and and data science to
grapple uh with these utterly daunting challenging
but critical issues of navigating across scales
in a way that captures the way that these brain
networks somehow manage to work i've been very
interested in computational neuroscience since
literally the mid-80s and have been excited to
see progress on many fronts including efforts to
to bridge this gap between micro meso macro scales
as we one of the ways we can parse that but i also
my feeling is that we haven't really um broken
through uh the ice and and gotten into uh
a rich exploratory strategy that uh yields uh the
the the deep pay dirt uh it it's partly because
we don't have the computational tools yet uh there
i think there's tremendous room for innovation on
strategies for modeling uh complex networks that
that have to be invented i i don't feel like
it's just a matter of taking existing tools
and running with it we need smart uh people
uh developing new computational strategies in
conjunction uh with the ability to cope with
these staggering amounts of data that i've
touched upon from these multimodalities so
i i've made the point uh kate on occasion
that when i was in a student a postdoc in
the 1970s working with huble and weasel i
had this absolute illusion that they had
stolen or not stolen they had just taken the the
cream of what's to be discovered in neuroscience
and published it and got their nobel prize and
what was left for us to mop up was just uh uh
leftovers and nothing could be farther from the
truth i i've come to realize they deserve their
nobel prize they and many other pioneers but what
we have yet to understand about the brain keeps
looming larger and larger the more we know
the more there is to that we really have to uh
have yet to learn in terms of the data and
deciphering how it actually works so it's
tremendously exciting and will be so for literally
decades to come david you've been involved with
various aspects of the sharing of data for as long
as i have known you and the there's a sociology
behind sharing which i think in the early days
was almost uh it just crippling people were
just so nervous about doing it and now it almost
seems like it's just expected that you do it and
i'm just curious if you have any war stories or
thoughts about how data have kind of become fair
as you know capital f-a-i-r and what lessons you
have learned from the human connect dome project
patience i would say is one of the things that you
and i both had to learn because i think we both
acutely recall those early days it was an uphill
battle and and we were in another analogy voices
in the wilderness saying hey guys it's really
really important to share data and as you kind
of alluded to get anything from blank stares to
struggle with shoulders to resistance hostility i
don't want to do it don't bother me to uh i'd love
to do it i have no idea how and indeed knowing how
back in those days was impractical so i i think
you and i and many others have had to be patient
with the the evolution of the
methodology as well as the sociology
uh to where we now are at long last uh uh a
couple of decades later uh the the the attitude
is radically different in in the
community in the younger generation
and indeed is saying of course we should share
and how do we do it how do we help but um
taking the long view has been important for folks
like you and me well i couldn't agree more um one
final question before we wrap things up is uh
what do you see as the role of the understanding
of both structural and functional connectivity
in understanding neurological disease
uh again it's hugely important um i think you
know there have been hypotheses for example
that certain disorders schizophrenia or autism
are exemplified by quote over connectivity
or under connectivity as suggested by fmri
particularly wrestling state fmri or other
tractography as well to me those are you know
a first crack at trying to uh uh crack the nut
and get down to the the meat of the issue
i think is exceedingly unlikely that the
neurological disorders uh will be explained in
such a simple way and that's one of the reasons
why i'm intensely interested in exploring how one
can take resting state fmri data as powerful and
enticing as it is and probe it more deeply
and beyond just looking at simple correlations
or even partial correlations which we've tried
and doesn't actually help as much as we might
have hoped in kind of cleaning up the the signal
and getting better estimates of actual wiring like
connectivity so i think we need animal models and
we need an intense commitment by the field to say
we've got to go way past correlation and
figure out somehow using better data and
better analysis strategies to infer what
does this these what do these signals tell us
and how do we interpret them in much more nuanced
and complicated sophisticated ways as to what the
malfunction dysfunctions are in brain disorders
like autism schizophrenia and many others
david with that let me thank you very much for
sharing uh this amazing body of work with us
and giving us some words of wisdom as we uh
kind of undertake our own interests here in
uh neuroscience neuroimaging neuroscience
generally across spatial and temporal scales
um thank you so much i really appreciate it and uh
want to wish everybody who's listening in a very
good weekend and once again dr venice and
thank you so much thank you my pleasure